[Música]
vivo en caracas y tengo la fortuna de
tener una ventana que me permite ver el
cerro ávila ese icono que para esta
ciudad tan tan importante es desde esa
ventana he visto en semanas recientes
una extraordinaria migración de mariposa
no sé si alguien más por acá al habrá
visto pero al menos en la zona norte de
la ciudad durante muchos días semanas
enteras ahí van pasando una tras otra
tras otra tras otra llenando de alegría
de vivacidad de color de brillo esa esa
ventana que tanto agradezco y estas
mariposas con su amarillo con su
amarillo extraordinario me hacen pensar
por un lado y cuántas habrán pasado o no
en cuántas cuántas mariposas habrán para
sobre cien mil doscientos 500 mil un
millón de mariposas quién sabe escuché
decir que gabriel garcía márquez el gabo
en alguna oportunidad de sus tiempos
mozos frecuentando caracas ciudad que
mucho amor
en vida
presenció también una de estas
migraciones de mariposas amarillas quizá
decía esta fuente quizás fue esto lo que
le inspiró a incluirlas en esa narrativa
extraordinaria de sus 100 años de
soledad
la migración cuántos venezolanos han
migrado
seguramente muchos más de los que mi
imaginación pudiera alcanzar a atrapar
5 millones probablemente más un
porcentaje importantísimo de los que en
esta tierra hemos nacido están probando
suerte en otras partes del mundo a
diferencia de las mariposas que veía
pasar solamente como de el lado
occidental hacia el oriental de caracas
a diferencia de ellas los venezolanos
han migrado a los cuatro puntos
cardinales cada uno de ellos con la
justificación absolutamente válida y
respetable está probando suerte en otras
partes pero no son solamente ellos
también estamos quienes dentro de las
fronteras geográficas tradicionales de
lo que se llamaba venezuela seguimos
pues acá inventando cosas
en una oportunidad y puesto producto del
trabajo que yo desarrollo como como
músico y como persona que hace tours por
por el mundo en una oportunidad estaba
yo en canadá estaba en un territorio
gigantesco que se llama albert está
puntualmente en una ciudad llamada
edmonton ciudad petrolera por cierto yo
presentarme en ese lugar extraordinario
hacía un frío increíble 13 grados bajo
cero tormenta de nieve
en un desayuno de estos tipos buffet de
hotel me cruzo
fortuitamente con un caballero mayor
amabilísimo como son los canadienses
quien es muy buena onda me pregunta
amigo si usted de dónde viene se notaba
que yo no soy canadiense y entonces yo
le respondo yo soy de venezuela y saben
ustedes que me ha dicho me ha dicho este
amigo yo conozco de venezuela yo conozco
yo he oído de venezuela me dice este
amigo me quedo yo pensando en esta
respuesta de él a lo que yo pregunto que
ustedes de acá ustedes acá de edmonton
me dicen no yo no soy de edmonton yo
vivo en una ciudad que se llama hello
knife algo así como cuchillo amarillo
yellowknife búsqueda en google está en
el norte en ort y ximo prácticamente en
el círculo polar ártico y ahí me
pregunta vuelve y se refresca como
alguien que vive geográfica y
culturalmente tan lejos de venezuela
conoce de mi país que habrá escuchado
noticias buenas noticias malas
y le pregunto
y usted amigo que conoce de mi país y la
respuesta de este amigo de yellowknife
una ciudad pequeña que está al norte
norte en el polo norte una ciudad que
tiene además 25 mil habitantes no más de
eso él me ha dicho yo conozco venezuela
porque en mi pueblo en yellowknife
hacen arepas hay venezolanos cocinando
arepas y yo he comido arepas de ese
tamaño de ese tamaño en el fenómeno de
la migración de venezuela estaba yo en
madrid en españa
conocemos a una amiga también nacida en
venezuela quien nos cuenta que en la
puerta de su casa colocó un letrero en
el pórtico en la parte superior de la
entrada colocó el letrero que dice
venezuela venezuela en la entrada de su
casa dice venezuela y nos pareció muy
bonito y le preguntamos y eso porque
aquí viene esa iniciativa que tal
cuéntanos y la respuesta de ella fue
extraordinariamente poderosa ella nos
dice yo le he colocado el nombre de
venezuela a la puerta de mi casa porque
mis niños pequeñitos ambos que están
creciendo en españa que van al colegio y
bueno justamente cuando regresan del
cole como le dicen allá cuando regresan
del cole
yo quiero nos comenta ella yo quiero que
mis amos cuando entren a casa
vean y entiendan dónde está el hogar
siendo así
esta nueva venezolanidad
no es otra cosa que una creación
conjunta
donde todos
estamos obligados a hacerla algo
extraordinario
a mí
[Música]
y
ya mañana es el día tus maletas están
listas debes llegar por lo menos 4 horas
ante el aeropuerto simón bolívar no
conciliar el sueño
sientes que tu alma se vacía que inmenso
el vértigo se vienen todos los recuerdos
de tu vida los que se quedan los que se
van algún día volverán los que se quedan
los que se van algún día
en otra tierra será semilla una nueva
casa una familia echarás palante como un
elefante valiente primero y constante
cuando golpes en la melancolía con tus
postales tu música tu comida miras con
orgullo de dónde vienes a estar a tu
corazón cuando tú te conectes los que se
quedan los que se van algún día volverán
los que se quedan los que se van
algún día
él
y mientras tanto quienes están en
venezuela se preguntan cosas como esta
todos los días
dónde está juan está en panamá donde
está el luisa está en suiza y christina
en argentina y la gorda en colombia y
ramón en japón oyendo oscar d'león
patricia en canadá esperanza está en
francia
antonio aurora y bet están en el sur y
más en india tarareando simón díaz nadie
en españa sofía en turquía
vanessa en méxico fernando está en chile
la cucha en escocia nicanor en ecuador
estrella en italia friendo empanadas
carlito en alemania natalista en brasil
and en dominicanas recordando llorón y
el humanista en arabia la maracucha este
en rusia
manuela en australes pero quisiera estar
en caracas
los que se quedan los que se van algún
día volverán los que se quedan los que
se van y algún día
aunque hay muchas muchas maneras de
volver desde aquella en la cual alguien
recoge sus cosas nos meten en una maleta
en un container y si dice venezuela es
mi propósito de vida ahora otros que no
que manteniéndose en cualquier rincón
del planeta
cada día
recordando y conectándose estará en el
eterno retorno los que se quedan los que
se van algún día volverán los que se
quedan los que se van
algún día
volverá
qué es el arte maya pregunta complicada
de responder
el arte se parece mucho a los milagros
saben por qué porque al final del día
lo único que exige la existencia del
arte o la existencia de los milagros es
que haya un cambio de percepción si yo
necesito ver un milagro créanme que lo
voy a ver en cualquier lugar voy a ver
los milagros el milagro de la vida de la
sonrisa de un niño del amanecer será un
milagro porque necesito verlo
exactamente así ocurre con el arte
nosotros podemos encontrar la maravilla
de la creación también en cualquier
lugar donde nuestros anhelos lo
necesiten
sin embargo
yendo ya un poco más aterrizado al tema
de el arte como obra de la creación
humana creación que tiene además un
propósito estético el arte debería ser
libre no cree en ustedes seguramente lo
creen al igual que yo el arte debe
obedecer a las necesidades de expresión
de los creadores y qué maravilla si es
bien recibida por sus audiencias dentro
de la amplísima gama de expresiones del
arte existe una que es lo que algunos
llaman el arte de raigambre de inquietud
social
es ese el arte en el que la obra de este
que está acá pues se ha movido durante
ya algunos años entonces de dónde viene
la inspiración de ese arte social
a veces vamos a la panadería a veces
vamos a una reunión social reunión
familiar a veces estamos en el
transporte público a veces leemos lo que
escribe la gente en redes sociales y la
gente tiene opiniones la gente tiene
visiones del mundo que les está tocando
del país que les está tocando vivir a
veces padecer ya veces festejar
eso que algunos en las ramas de los
estudios de la comunicación social o los
estudios de la politología llaman la
opinión pública ahí en gran medida en el
pensamiento y reflexión de la gente en
gran medida está lo que a este que está
acá le ha inspirado a escribir a
escribir canciones canciones contra la
violencia canciones contra la
delincuencia canciones rabiosas contra
quienes desde el poder han hecho muy mal
uso de sus atribuciones pero también la
autocrítica que tienen las personas
acerca de sus congéneres acerca de
quienes viven en la cuadra acerca de sus
propios comportamientos en comunidad
estaba llega una oportunidad en choroní
hermosísimo pueblo que probablemente
muchos de ustedes que me están
escuchando y viendo en este momento
conozcan o hayan oído hablar de si no lo
han hecho los invito también a que lo
busquen en internet llorón y es un
pueblo que está en el hermoso fantástico
caribe venezolano en el estado aragua
y en ese pueblo estaba yo en una
oportunidad de fiesta de parranda una
fiesta de esas a todos a todas bailando
bebiendo pasándola súper bien como a las
4 y 30 de la mañana a esa hora
mágica ya ya yo no daba más me iba me
iba a la posada en la cual me hospedaba
y voy a descansar y caminando rumbo a la
casita pues al hotel donde yo me meo
cuidado me cruzó en el camino con unos
pescadores pescadores que estaban
preparando sus aparejos sus redes qué sé
yo para montarlas en sus peñeros en sus
lanchas e irse a la faena cuatro y media
de la mañana yo llegaba de la rumba
ellos comenzaban su faena de trabajo
esperaban sólo quizá que despuntara el
alba para salir a su chamba
en ese momento se me ocurre
que somos un montón de gente
creando de manera colectiva de manera
conjunta a este país
a este momento histórico a este mundo
tan convulso todos absolutamente todos
vivimos en un lugar que despierta bajo
un mismo sol
bueno
no no
[Música]
y bueno
que despierta
bajo el mismo sol
[Música]
entre millones de corazones que palpita
con fuerza que hacen que la tierra
tiembla
está cansada de crisis miseria y guerra
urbana gente que trabaja y piensa
trabaja y piensa que trabaja duro y sin
recompensa
[Música]
sin recompensa
encuentre gente que tiene paciencia y
esperanza que sabe que las cosas buenas
llegan pero suelen ser las que más
tardan
que quiere echar para fuera
qué son las peores consejeras
y esa misma gente quiere que la tierra
tiembla
tiempo
para que se caigan los mal parados que
entraban la puerta que entraba la muerte
que entraba en la puerta para que se
vayan esos vampiros así se abran nuevos
caminos la tierra tiembla
[Música]
hembras
yo no me voy de aquí
y hasta que revienta
tengo un ancestro africano tengo un
hermano latinoamericano tengo un primo
al que le llaman lindo y él no entiende
de racismo solo pide que le dejen
tranquilo y mientras tanto el norte
sigue mirando hacia abajo y el sur se ve
más a sí mismo y se está hinchando
ustedes saben qué es lo que pasa en la
calle
de todo
[Música]
la tierra tiembla
la tierra
[Música]
y tiembla porque la hacemos temblar
entonces en qué quedamos
es la sociedad la que inspira a el arte
o es el arte el que inspira a la
sociedad
quién cambia a quién quién modifica
quién es y si más bien pensamos en que
el arte es parte consustancial de la
sociedad parte consustancial de la
historia veamos justamente la historia
entera de la humanidad humanidad sin
arte no es como obviamente arte sin
humanidad sin sociedad carece de sentido
viéndolo de esta manera
el arte sin lugar a dudas es parte
del cambio es parte del cambio
justamente cuando las sociedades han
decidido cambiar en este mundo
tan convulso en este tiempo tan
complicado tan atribulado
tiene sentido
que el arte forme parte de sus castillos
que generen los cambios yo creo que sí
por supuesto creo que sí
pero este arte tiene que decir cosas
este arte tiene que plantar cara este
arte tiene que ser confort monta tivo
rebelde atreverse a poner el dedo donde
muchos preferirían
no ponerlo
creo yo aquí si me permite hacer una
reflexión personal creo yo que ese arte
además debería ser inclusivo
un arte que hable
de manera ética por qué no decirlo y que
permita que ahí frente a él se genera un
espacio de convivencia tolerante y buena
onda donde puedan estar personas de las
más distintas procedencias
distintas creencias ideológicas
políticas religiosas personas con
distinta procedencia geográfica en el
mundo con distintas identidades
culturales qué delicia que un arte
permita eso que permita que estén ahí
personas con distinto color de piel que
permita que estén ahí conviviendo y
reflexionando juntos personas con
distintas preferencias sexuales personas
que tengan distintas capacidades
motrices cognitivas sensoriales que
estén ahí independientemente de la edad
digo yo que un arte que permita el
encuentro de los seres humanos para que
ellos crezcan en su propia reflexión y
en sus propias necesidades sería
extraordinario y yo
agradecería mucho que ese arte tenga los
pies bien puestos en el piso
no necesariamente para ser terrenal
porque el arte debería volar pero me
refiero a que los pies en el piso
permiten siempre saber cuál es la
estatura que tenemos
viéndolo así entonces el arte para un
mundo convulso es sin lugar a dudas el
producto de la creación conjunta
una creación conjunta en la que cada uno
de nosotros debería ojalá que así nos lo
propusiera mos como meta de nuestras
comunidades desde la primera persona del
singular a la primera persona del plural
nos permitiera conseguir nuestro propio
propio brillo que nos permitiría
conseguir la mejor versión de nosotros
mismos porque todos cada uno de nosotros
es fuerte
y es poderoso
fuertes poderosos todos cada uno de
nosotros a menos que no haya inspiración
puñalada trapera a la fácil la
imaginación rebelde por siempre rebelde
hasta la muerte que el destino un
perdone el cansancio de la edad a la que
llegues
nunca voy a esperar morirme de hambre va
a ganar lo que
cuando podré yo perdí a mi mamá
[Música]
de sordera
eres un vendaje placas
[Música]
combate
empuja empuja y empuja corazón empuja
sangre roja corajudas desde este lado de
mi pecho quiero estar presente en la
masacre de las penas de los alambres
después de las urnas injustas quiero
estar presente y que mejoren las
escuelas miren mi pana que el que no
inventa yerra nunca voy a esperar
morirme de hambre para cantar lo que me
duele caracoles cascabeles para saber
cuándo podré yo verte ay mamá
y verdad cuando será dímelo tú me iré
a pesar de estar en la calle
desorden está en la calle
ah
por dentro
en la calle y en ella desorden está en
la calle combate
[Música]
combate
para ti
[Música]
caracas